care for your team if you want your team
to give you everything they have then
you have to care about them most people
hate their boss and soon as most bosses
suck and most bosses don't care about
their team when you hire somebody when
you hire an employee they're bringing in
their brain to you and they're going to
do what they need to do when you care
about your team then they're going to
give you their heart and soul and
they're going to put everything they
have into helping you accomplish your
mission it's not that hard you just have
to care and show them I'm reminded of a
story by estro Kathy who's the founder
of chick-fil-a and one year he had a
really bad year and his team his
management in Kingdom is that hey you
know we need to we need to trim sour
expenses we need to trim because we
can't afford to pay all these people and
the options that gave him were either
one fire some people fire some employees
or to reduce their salaries asked him to
take a pay cut he didn't want that to
happen and he came up with a third
option and that was him not taking a
salary full full year because he cared
about his team he knew how important
they were to him he didn't want to let
them go and what do you think that did
for the team one of the worst things
that happened to a team is when a
company is not doing well and there's
layoffs people are worried for their
jobs that doesn't inspire great things
but what he did he turned out on his
head he said I believe in you guys I
need you guys to stay I care for you i
want you and as a result him not taking
a salary for a year showed them that he
cared about them and they in turn gave
everything they had for him and they
believed in him they believed in him in
his vision what he was building you
don't have to go to that extreme you
know you may not be able to afford not
to take a salary for a year just show
people that you care
out them asked how they're doing learn
about what their dreams in their vision
is see what they're doing in their job
that maybe you can help make easier just
care it'll make you feel better and
it'll make your team feel more inspired
I'm more loyal and give you everything
they have for you if you don't then
people are going to leave you and you're
always going to wonder why you can't
attract and keep top talent if people
love what they're doing they believe in
their meshes message and they feel
valued they're never going to leave you
they're going to give you everything
they have you're going to own their
heart and soul and you're going to build
a great company believe if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes me do more of these videos for
you and I want to hear what you have to
think let me know in the comments
section if you like this video and I
want to hear if you have a question for
your business please leave in the
comment section below I read those every
day it really makes my morning when I
seem to come in so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode